est-ce que vous pouvez définir ce que
c'est que la droite en quelques mots
c'est de l'ordre c'est de l'ordre c'est
de la concorde et c'est de la liberté de
l'ordre ça veut dire quoi remettre la
sécurité 32% de hausse des violences
c'est ça le bilan des manuels macron de
l'ordre frontières ça veut dire une
vraie politique migratoire de l'ordre à
l'école remettre l'école sur pied et
puis c'est réparé complètement ce pays
aujourd'hui vous soyez bien qu'on a un
pays qui complètement divisé
complètement clivé avec une présidence
verticale qui n'a pas fait confiance ni
aux territoires ni aux français donc moi
je propose le référendum d'initiative
populaire je propose une grande loi de
décentralisation est une vraie réforme
de l'état avec moi l'état lâchera prise
je suis le contraire de la présidence
jupitérienne en salle et sur apprises je
suis là président la présidente c'est de
la décentralisation
on fera confiance aux données du pouvoir
à ce que je dis et que eric zemmour ne
dit pas c'est que moi je ne me résigne
ray jamais parce que je pense qu'une
autre politique est possible et c'est
pour ça que je propose une grande loi
migratoire avec des quotas avec un
principe zéro visas pour les pays qu'ils
reprennent pas leurs clandestins avec
plus de regroupement familial
automatique avec plus de l'acquisition
de la nationalité
automatique du droit du sol automatique
pour moi nationalité française elle se
demande elle se mérite donc une vraie
politique pour reprendre le contrôle de
cette immigration incontrôlée deux cent
soixante douze mille titres de séjour
donné cette année par emmanuel macron
c'est une bérézina migratoires emmanuel
macron a dit je ne veux pas de quotas il
va je ne comprends pas parce que les
états unis ont des quotas le canada ont
dès à des quotas est aujourd'hui c'est
la seule politique possible et j'y
reviendrai dès cette semaine